[Music]
hello and welcome to the introductory
video of AWS database migration service
course offered by simply learn I spent
over 15 years working as a database
administrator for large investment banks
in London Sydney and New York supporting
Microsoft sequel server SAP ASE my
sequel and Oracle in 2015 I decided to
set up database of all my own company so
that I could concentrate on the areas of
technology that are most passionate
about cloud computing and databases
after using many of the major cloud
providers out there I decided to focus
solely on Amazon Web Services as it
truly is the best in the business in
this video we will go over some
interesting information about why this
service is so innovative and useful so
why are database migrations so difficult
database migrations are complex as they
involve so many different areas of an IT
department from sis admins to storage
from network administrators to DBAs and
migrations can be affected by a
multitude of different issues for
example slow Network speed the size of
the database or type migration deadlines
further complexity can be created if the
migration involves a change of database
platform all of these reasons and many
more make database migrations are
complex time-consuming and risky process
what is AWS database migration service
well AWS DMS is an innovative service
that aims to simplify migrating
databases into the cloud it allows you
to perform homogeneous migrations
like-for-like migrations for example
Oracle to Oracle or sequel server the
sequel server but it also allows you to
do heterogeneous migrations which are
cross-platform migrations for example
sequel server to MySQL
and you can use the service to
consolidate data from multiple sources
into a single database and what's more
you can also perform continuous data
replication with high availability so
that your database migration can take
place over a period of time rather than
in a short defined window sounds great
right but why would you want to migrate
your databases to the cloud well there
are many reasons but here are just a few
cost moving your database infrastructure
to AWS offers huge savings for
everything from instances to storage
managed services AWS offers a service
called RDS which provides full
management of the database so you don't
have to worry about backups maintenance
or high availability if you want to
switch database platforms to escape from
the expensive Oracle or Microsoft
licensing you can use AWS DMS to migrate
your platform to something much cheaper
for example MySQL or Amazon Aurora and
scalability the AWS cloud is completely
scalable so you can increase and reduce
resources based on demand and you only
pay for what you use simply learns AWS
database migration course comprises of
four hours of eLearning
quiz questions at the end of each lesson
and one evaluation project you will get
teachings assistance support from the
simply learned staff anytime during the
course and for the project's queries can
also be submitted at help and support on
WW simply learn comm or you can get
connected with the staff on simply talk
and the live chat options prerequisites
for this course are a knowledge of
databases and a limited understanding of
AWS products and services and that's
about it go ahead and begin AWS database
migration service course and get started
with the first lesson today happy
learning